[Music]
charter school authorizing is important
it helps ensure that charter schools are
responsible stewards and their students
and of public funds good authorizers
don't give license to mediocrity if they
must also protect the autonomy that
enables vibrant schools to flourish it
snacks the president gregg/richmond has
observed in both the red and blue states
last year we saw legislation proposed
that would have dictated what a charter
school should be rather than what
outcomes taxpayers should hold it
accountable for these bills required
certain curriculum certain discipline
models and certain teacher principal and
staff certification requirements look
the easiest thing in the world is to
insist on just one more rule that
charter school should follow but the
accretion of rules over time creates a
sclerosis that leaves school stuck and
educators frustrated if charter schools
are to deliver on their promise
authorizers must help ensure that
educators can create terrific classrooms
and not simply to recreate familiar
hidebound bureaucracies what do you
think about charter schools let us know
in our poll also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI